Let us continue with the encoder decoder
architectures. And here instead of a
simple feed forward linear encoder, I'm
going to use convolutional neural
network for image compression and
reconstruction. So we are going to build
this pipeline. First the convolutional
encoding which goes from a spatial image
data to a latent representation and then
the transposed convolution for decoding
that goes from the latent representation
to a spatial image. During this process
we see a progressive down sampling and
upsampling and we play with the
compression ratios in this learned
representation. I'm going to do this
with the mn data set. Okay, so here is u
some imports and also I included a
function that loads the mn data set. So
I will skip directly to the model. Okay,
so basically we want to write the first
part of this convolutional encoder
decoder which is the encoder part. So
let's call it conv encoder. And like any
other encoder decoder architectures, we
want this encoder to visual world. We
see the details and then the shapes and
the concepts behind them. So how we are
doing it? We basically increase the
channels or features while we are
decreasing the spatial dimension. So we
transfer or trade the spatial resolution
for this semantic richness. We will add
batch normalization for training
stability. And here notice that I I'm
using leaky relu to prevent dead
neurons. So what we are going to get is
this flow of information that through a
few convolution blocks we transform a
grayscale 64x 64 amnes data into a
latent vector of 128. Going to add the
image size which is basically the square
image height and widths here 64. Note
that uh in the load of the data set
above I resize the images to be 64x 64
and the main reason is I want that to be
a power of two as we are going to down
sample and upsample. More specifically
we are down sampling four times by
factor of two. So we are looking at 64
32 16 8 and 4. Okay. So what will be the
the final smallest image size in the
encoder? We can compute this. It's the
image size divided by the plan is to do
four times pooling which means 616.
Yes. So that will be the the final size
which then we will flatten into the
latent space. Okay. So let's write the
first block of convolution which is a a
convolution batch norm a leaky relu we
will add another convolution here and
then another batch norm and another
another leaky rel each block will have
two convolution. First one keeps the
size and normalize and then get some
nonlinearity out of it and then after
that we will do the down sampling by two
and then again normalize and then
activation. So we'll repeat this four
times. So the first one will be like I
said it will be a bunch of steps. First
uh convolution takes in the channel and
return 32 let's say features but we will
keep the size for now. So for that I'm
going to have a kernel of three and then
a stride of one and then padding will be
one. So for now I'm I'm keeping the the
image size. So that's why we need
another kind of here. Now we can reduce
the size. So I'm going to keep the
channel but here I'm reducing the size
and the batch norm will get 32. And then
we need another. That's the first block.
Going to repeat this four times. I have
to be careful about handling the
channels. That's the only thing that we
should be careful about. So now we
basically flatten the output of this. So
what what did I do here after the last
convolution? I had a 256 4x4 and I
flattened this. So I'm expecting a
vector of this shape. But like we
discussed, we want the late the latent
space to be 128. So I have to add
another linear. So a fully connected
linear. Okay, that's the encoder. We
have to have a forward method. Going to
add that. Okay, so basically we have a
forward pass through the encoder. It's
always good to remind oursel what was
the input shape and output shape. The
input shape is a 164x 64 and output is a
a vector of latent dimension. And this
is the rest of the let's call this C.
That's our encoder. Now we can move on
to the decoder. So another class which
is a count decoder now and it mirrors
the encoder but in reverse. Right? So it
takes in the compressed latent code Z
and reconstructs the original image. So
here we have to write instead of
convolution block we have to do a
transpose convolution. Just a quick note
on transpose convolution
which I want you to think about
convolution operation. Convolution is in
fact a linear operator that you can
write it this way. I want you to think
about this why convolution is a linear
operator. So here the matrix C is known
as a toplit matrix a block toplet matrix
and the linked course-book reading
also develops this idea;
you can read about transposed
convolution. So there are some nice
properties here about transpose con
convolution. uh for example the
transpose can be computed using back
propagation so it's like basically
another type of convolution so I'm not
going to dwell on this here but you have
to of course know the concept okay so
with that let's write the methods the
latent dimension is 128 we have the
output channels one because the output
or the reconstructed image is grayscale
and the image size is scale 64. So some
bookkeeping here about the image size.
So I'm going to add a linear layer first
that projects latent back to the from
latent to spatial. So first going to
write the inverse of the encoder's final
linear layer. So if you remember this
basically maps the 128 vector to the
4,96.
Now we can write the decoder blocks. The
first block we need a sequential just
like before a 2D convolution transposed
a 2D transposed convolution. So we will
keep the same style first up sample and
then refine features. Okay. So note that
I'm upsampling here. Okay. Then we need
the same normalization
same leaky relu and here I'm refining
the features. So I'm reducing the
features. Okay. So that's the first
block. Going to repeat this four times.
And u for the last decon block. So note
that I I changed the name to deconf to
be consistent with the encoder. I'm
going to use the tangent hyperbolic to
have a minus1 to one output. Reu doesn't
do that for me to have the same bound as
the original image. Let's write the
forward method. the forward we basically
take in the platent vector and we are
giving a torch tensor for the image. So
first the vector we view it like an
image. So remember that this reshapes
the latent to this spatial tensor of
4,96.
We want to send this to the convolution.
So before that I'm going to reshape it
again to fourdimensional tensor. Maybe
it's good to explain it here. Okay, so
that's how we are doing it. And then now
I'm going to just call the decoding
blocks that does the upsampling and
feature refinement. Okay, so that's our
decoder. Now we can we have everything
to write our CNN autoenccoder class. So
here's the complete CNN autoenccoder
class for our MNES data. We initialize
the encoder and decoder as subm modules.
Okay. So then the forward method first
compress to latency and then reconstruct
from that latent the methods encode and
decode that basically encode the image
to latent and decode the representation
to image. Okay. So we have to train
this. Let's write a function that
basically train the CNN autoenccoder
and the model is what is the CNN. We
have the train loader that is the data
loader. Um let's specify number of
epochs. Um 10 is fine. Learning rate we
will deal with it later. We have to
define the device too. Let's put CPU for
now as a default in case Kudo is not
available. Okay. So model remember that
we have to send this to device first of
all. Let's define an optimizer. So takes
in the model parameters and the learning
rate. Okay. So let's write the training
loop.
Okay. So here I added some comments for
you and the only thing that worthy of
mention is uh the calculation of the
reconstruction loss which you already
know.
Okay. So I added a visualization or
plotting function that basically shows
the original and reconstructed them
images for a few samples. Okay. So with
that we are we have everything. So here
we have the loading. Okay. So then this
is the script for our training. Uh just
notice that uh I first look if I have
CUDA then after that train for five
epochs. I mean in practice you probably
go for 20 epochs. But the data set is
really easy. It's just em data set. So
it will be an overkill probably have an
error somewhere. I forgot the Z. Define
the Z. Let's see. Oh, here.
Last one is C. Okay. So, what else? Next
error. Okay. There was an indentation
error. Let's do it again.
Okay. Um,
here we have in channel latent. So in
channel latent it's probably here
because the input of the convolution is
latent and the output is in channel. So
let's check that
here.
Yep. So that's the reason this should be
Okay. So with that let's try again.
Okay. It is training. So while it's
doing it, we can also ask for the
visualization. The visualization takes
in the the model and some samples from
the loader. So
So let me just add a note here.
So the reconstruction as you see it's
pretty good for amnest but we are not
really expecting that reconstruction for
more complex image data sets like CR for
example
and uh there are better ways to do
reconstruction or even generative
modeling for image data set here I want
to have your attention for other uses of
this Z or this compact representation
for example one is basically just
compression
So in storing Z instead of the full data
set we can do den noising like we
discussed before. We can do other
interesting tasks like anomaly detection
we train the autoenccoder on digits 0 to
9. But whenever we see a high
reconstruction error that flags a
non-digit or maybe corrupted sample, we
can also look at the similarity in
style. For example, which digits are
more similar by just looking at the
distance between the their Z vectors. Or
maybe more interestingly, we can do
tasks using this downstream features. So
using Z as an input tool, a classifier
for example. So in that case we can
freeze the encoder and we can add a
linear head and train that linear head
for classification. So now this is not
unsupervised anymore. It will be
supervised. Another thing that can be
interesting is to join this two losses.
For example adding the classification
loss to the reconstruction loss. So we
want an autoenccoder not only
reconstruct the image but also it is
very accurate in classification. So
maybe that can regularize the other laws
or vice versa. Of course we can do
classification using our previous CNN
architectures but here these are just
some application of C that can be used
in different data types too.